to GameSpot's continuing coverage of e3
2015 a lot of people talking about how
interesting sony's conference was load
of new games coming out an app but one
of the things about that conference was
is it not many games coming out in 2015
and not the same can be said for
Microsoft and one of those games is
coming out real soon is that for two
motorsports six on a delighted to be
joined by mr. Don great often turn 10
absolutely good to see you again sir and
another year another force a game and
this one seems like it's a pretty big
endeavor though it is absolutely and
you're right you know fourth was really
accelerated over the years sports of
five was there at launch and that
allowed us to get our engine up and
running on the Xbox one which was
fantastic we've been able to just build
new features and iterate listen to our
fans and then Forza horizon 2 which just
recently last week Porsche was added for
ties into an expansion yeah and now
September 15 for two motorsports six
which is the biggest game we've ever
built it's interesting was a bunch of
big forts of fans in the office myself
included and when the expansion pack
came out last week it was like oh great
nothing ever comes out right before he 3
so something to to play with and then it
almost becomes like this sort of season
where you've got your you've got your
your core as circuit season where you're
playing your forward to games and then
when the horizon games come at it's like
the offseason you kind of just do a
little you know different type of style
driving and i love it when players love
both but obviously the reason we have
both is to service people who just love
cars generally so there's people to play
both there's people to just play horizon
there's people to just play motorsport
and that's wonderful because the
franchise is all about getting people
into cars and getting people into games
so you know teach their own but my
favorite of people that like them both
yeah and let's get into the nitty-gritty
because this is a series which you
really have to get into the finer points
and let's talk about water first of all
I'm a massive fan of formula one and one
of the most the biggest changes that can
happen in a race is when it starts to
rain and what are you guys doing with
water in terms of how that changes up a
circuit in terms of grip in terms of how
you attack an individual circuit
absolutely so our fans have wanted wet
and their rain you know and night in
ports it for a long time but of course
the reason they wanted is they want it
done in a forts away right high quality
1080p 60 frames per second and now we
have 24 cars on track drivatar or
multiplayer which makes it really packed
now the way thats related to
and night is the tension if your driver
driving the wet and I come from seattle
where it rains all the time I don't come
from Ireland so right we're in the same
focus so the big thing was not just
having a diminishment of grip that
wasn't enough we went through and
studied you know brands hatch which we
have actually you know in the demo 148
race to surface types on that track
we're talking you know sealant versus
concrete different types of tarmac and
they all have different porosities I'm
gonna geek out for a second that's how
the water is actually absorbed into the
surface we did all the research to get
that just right so if you put one tire
on the the painted rumble strip for
example it's going to get very different
friction it might pull you in orda based
on the rumble strip it might slip you
out but the big thing is puddles ya know
you hydroplane in puddles in the real
world span Lewis Hamilton that last
weekend in Canada and that will make you
pay attention yeah so for two
motorsports six we have puddles that's
not just sound and splash but you hide
your plane through them the car can spin
out and when there's 24 cars around yeah
it's very very intense are those puddles
that I'd one of the things that's
interesting about water and how it
changes during a race throws puzzles and
do they expand do they get bigger do
they appear in different parts of the
track or do you try and keep them
uniform because the other problem is if
they can appear anywhere it's hard to
sort of Judge whereabouts they might be
well they absolutely can't appear
anywhere because we went and researched
where the puddles show up so a track
like the Nurburgring has over 500
puddles and we went looked at where they
really show up I mean it just wart so
we're kind of known for doing this level
we walked the Nordschleife on her on a
wet day and just an yeah all right
there's one there's one look the best
job on turn 10 and the worst job I turn
as turn 10 is being a researcher yeah
you get to go to Ralph Lorenz garage and
photograph you know photograph 36
million dollar cars but you have to walk
the Nordschleife in the rain hmm take
the good with the bad yeah you gotta
give you gotta take absolute let's talk
about some of those super cars than last
year and the McLaren of course you guys
were showing off in the game this year
at four GT super is going to be in there
and tell us about as so that car and
some of the other cars you're going to
be bringing into fort so that we
wouldn't have seen in previous games
well you know this is a 10-year
anniversary of the fort's of franchise
and in those ten years we
seen a huge change in the industry
gaming industry and car industry back in
the original 42 motorsport we approached
car companies and said we'd love to have
your cars and again yeah and they were
you know warm to the idea yeah well
challenge them but okay well you know
we've been able to damage them this
whole time there's kind of a myth in the
industry that they don't want damage
yeah I don't know where that came from
we've had besides I'm ready to you we've
got damaged in for to midtown madness
you know all of our games so anyway the
10 years now gamers right III gamescom
games have become mainstream and so the
auto manufacturers want to tap into the
car passion yes in gamers we're their
best conduits and now they come to us
McLaren ford and ford actually was
giving us insider information from the
very beginning so very few people at
ford even knew this car was being built
and they started whispering to us hey we
got this this new thing we're working on
we can't tell you much but if you'd come
out to dearborn we might be able to show
you something cool so you know I was
actually there when Ford executives were
being told about the program and we had
already built it in the game so is this
incredible level of partnership and the
coolest thing is what this can be in the
future having millions of gamers drive
the 2017 for GT on LeMond before the car
is even finished being built yeah this
is a cool piece of feedback that we can
provide to the manufacturers like
playing their real-world products right
and so that's that's the power of gaming
that's the power of cloud computing is
the power of xbox live and it's how us
gamers are actually changing the world
now its automotive world but even so I
love that that's why I do this it was
interesting to see Henry for the third
up on stage with you during the
microsoft conference yeah and I think
especially for us on the press side
seeing me you guys are now in sports out
of forward events yeah that shows you
the the relationship that exists there
are more than anything else and let's
talk a bit more about a sort of I guess
they made the gameplay nature of the 42
series it's very much a loop of of on
doing different races unlocking
different cars unlocking stuff and
another driving games that I've really
enjoyed this year has been project cars
which took a different approach to it
and basically just said we don't really
maybe have the resources to cry
it's a sort of an unlockable thing we're
just going to give you all the circuits
and all the cars have you guys ever been
tempted to sort of tackled out or do you
think that the the unlockable nature of
Forza is what makes that Forza well the
thing i love about forts is the
diversity of our players we've got a
really diverse group of players you know
fifty percent in your a 50-percent North
America we've got a lot of women older
people younger people it's a game that
brings people together but that means
there's different motivations and great
design is all about empathy the
understanding your player is knowing who
you are so you're not blinded by your
own passions and really designing for
people and caring respecting what they
want so in ports of motorsport we've got
players to just love cars and loved
tracks they want to jump into those so
you can do that you can go into free
play play splitscreen I've got two kids
you know we can play with the kids you
can have a great time but if you're
looking for that kind of sit back and
progress and have a great time career
we've got a 70 plus our career called
stories of motorsport where we use the
450 cars I mean it's a lot of cars cars
that allows us to tell cool stories of
great rivalries and hopefully expose
people to eras of cars or Nicias of cars
they never knew about like pre-warp
Grand Prix cars right or the cigar cars
of the Grand Prix legends era right
getting people to a chance to experience
those is really great that's great for
the person who loves the 70-plus our
career but there's also multiplayer
there are people who you know couldn't
be bothered with free play and they
couldn't be bothered a campaign so to me
it's about respecting the type of
motivation of what brings you into the
game for the multiplayer we've got
leagues 24 car multiplayer on dedicated
server but leagues actually looks at
your skill and your temperament and puts
you into a very rigid group of people
just like you where you can have high
quality of service and really great
racing so you're not worried about it's
that guy fascinating mean slower than me
they're all similar that makes four
incredibly good racing and one of the
great things that you attitude is the
series I guess two games ago now and
we're drivin tars and I still get [ __ ]
from people on Twitter who say my Daniel
Dwyer drivatar it's just like fashion
into them and all the time whenever I
close the gap real quick I out of course
life and
that was a great addition but there was
some feedback from people saying look it
is more like racing sort of people who
are playing on their computers but it
doesn't feel like professional racing
because they're just almost like too
aggressive you guys are doing something
with sort of more professional AI as
well as an option is our yeah so the
drive charge system is amazing is
created water cooler talk Twitter talk
even as you're saying right where people
are just I never thought about opponents
and games this way yeah that they could
be and the thing I love is that I get
back to work and I've had a weekend of
racing against you know the guy that's
in the cube next to me and we had really
cool competitive racing and he was never
online and we talked about it and that's
what gaming's about right socializing
and having great time but you're right
fan said look I don't like when they run
into me when I'm playing a career I want
to kind of kick back and relax a little
bit so we added a toggle where you can
just make them more professional so
they're still going to have the
parameters of your friends but when the
AI wants to run into you and just kind
of slap some shackles on it and say no
we've also looked at the data we have
millions of players that have put data
into the servers from ports motorsport 5
and ports Orizon too we're able to train
them in ports of the motorsport six so
there's already your drivatar zara
lashing into people and say but all
sorry everyone yeah yeah so we're
testing on it right now but also we were
able to double click on the data and see
how fast drivers drive fast and how they
drive slow add more processing power to
the cloud and they learned new traits so
the humanity of the driver charger is
even greater in portsmouth sport 6 cool
I'm force Motorsports take said one of
the exciting games is actually coming at
this year in 2015 I'm brain well thank
you so much for culturally and before I
let you go when is it coming out and on
what platforms I wonder ports motorsport
6 is exclusively on the Xbox one and
it's shipping September 15 great just a
stone's throw away just a couple of more
f1 races away before I could dive back
into that and you want to thank everyone
who is watching us on gamespot of course
the YouTube III hub as well and our
partners over at hitbox we got a bunch
of great demos coming up over the next
couple of hours I'm up here for the next
hour and a half yeah but first of all
let's check out one of our little
breakouts this is about the xbox back
catalog as sponsored by msi let's check
it out
you